and we are right now joined by magnus
carlsen the winner
uh of a crazy day of kosher finals
congratulations magnus
thank you um it seems uh that this has
been quite a rollercoaster day for you
uh what has it been like
um i mean
obviously uh it's uh it's a relief
um the final result um
but um yeah
um that was a
thoroughly disgusting performance on my
part um
and um yeah
i i got to be got to be a lot better um
i feel like um
the preliminaries were
they were one step forward and this this
was
um two steps back but
um yeah at least i'm i'm through
uh it's better than than not being but
overall um
ah very very disappointing though jess
is it daniel dubose style
uh basically that that makes it hard for
you in some games here
uh no obviously he's a good player and
he thought
he fought well uh but
um yeah there are just so many avoidable
mistakes today
um like
especially the the
the second game um
because what didn't happen yesterday is
that
i gave him any life yesterday i didn't
give him any life
and by that second game by
by blundering um
by blundering there in in what seemed to
me
to be a very safe position where only i
can
can realistically play for a win by
giving him that
chance i feel like i gave him so much
life and uh
i i just completely unnerved me and
after after that i was uh was a shell of
myself to uh to be honest
um and
obviously that's partly due to the way
that he plays but i felt
in this case it was it was mostly
just a massive own goal and um
yeah these things these things shouldn't
shouldn't happen and
it's um it's um deeply
disappointing and we did see in that
second game magnus
we seen a lot of emotion from you today
and uh
you had a big laugh there um about
something could you tell us what that
wasn't
and did that sort of put you out of
focus to eventually lose that game
no that wasn't why i left can you tell
us what it was
i don't remember okay uh well mine is uh
you seem disappointed i can hear that
you are disappointed
what is it about uh for you now to sort
of get ready for semi-finals
against maximum vagiela grab no it's
just to uh
just to forget about today to be honest
and uh forget about yesterday as well
um yeah this
these two days don't matter it's it's
what happens uh tomorrow that matters
but
yeah right now it's uh
uh yeah as i said it's much better than
being out but it's um
pretty uh pretty bad day
all right well mine is we're definitely
looking forward to see you in the
semi-finals tomorrow good luck in that
thank you thanks for joining us